c'est dingue n'arrête pas de se croiser
oui mais qu'est ce qu'on fait ici j'ai
des livres ah bon bah oui je suis
libraire en fait je vais et alors vous
avez vu des choses intéressantes
écoutez je sais pas en fait je vais au
stand où il ya le plus de monde et je
passe commande
mais vous lisez jamais non à part le
mode d'emploi
je plaisante
et vous vous êtes cette seule la non on
finit avec des émirats et vous moi je
n'ai pas d'amis j'avais un chien vent
mais il est mort je plaisante faut que
j'arrête de faire de l'humour parce que
là je sens que ça va c'est quand je suis
gêné je peux pas m'empêcher on est là
tous nos titres et clermont moi quand
j'ai gêné j'entends plus rien
là j'ai entendu je vous trouve
magnifique merci non c'est vous qui
l'avez non non j'ai pas entendu je peux
dire ça bonjour bonjour